[Musique]
salut françois attire mon jour julie
comme notre jardin les beaux sous le
soleil à c'est vraiment bien agréable de
le voir comme ça c'est depuis que nous
avons installé ce système de nettoyage
un tour de rôle c'est une fameuse idée
tian bonjour vous êtes là nous sommes en
train de parler de la propreté du jardin
désormais il sera toujours impeccable
car nous sommes chargés chacun à tour de
rôle de nettoyer c'est une bonne idée
non
ils ont julie à propos qui est chargée
de nettoyer le jardin aujourd'hui à
temps il faut que je consulte le
calendrier qui établit l'ordre social
organisé le spot hier c'était moi
aujourd'hui c'est monsieur du snob au
parfait ce sera encore du travail à
faire mais pas par moi qu'est-ce que ça
c'est mon jour nomme ouais et alors me
dis donc j'ai pas fini de le lire du
poète un peu moins de 100 g
mais ne t'énerve quoi sierre ici alors à
m il m'a l'air de bien me résumer
aujourd'hui quasi mais qu'est ce que
c'est ce qui nous a même pas dit bonjour
bonjour julie bonjour kazimiya mais
coutu est embêtant aujourd'hui un
bonjour françois ça va très content
bon puisque c'est comme ça moi je te
dirai plus rire
casimir white qu'est ce que c'est
pourquoi tu jettes des papiers partout
comme ça ah bon alors toi aussi tu
prends parti contre moi bon ça que j'ai
mis une personne neutre en partie contre
toi bon alors laissez-moi faire mon pic
nic 30
c'est pas une raison pour mettre des
papiers partout c'est à chacun le jardin
les foyers chacun son tour
1 et aujourd'hui c'est à monsieur lui
snob qui se désunir c'est dans l'ombre
un sympathique d'abord un fromage
voilà des oeufs durs les thomas a le
gobelin voilà enfin julie julie
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire mal je ne
vois pas mais en tout cas ils exagèrent
vraiment regarded as l'air plus de voler
un autre koblet rate les assiettes et à
pour monsieur ghislain arabe up pour
mathieu du snarr pour monsieur du snarr
voilà ça c'est pour monsieur du snav les
aimer et l'eures casey ratt espace a tu
le fais exprès jeter des papiers par
terre
ouais et alors que tu sais que c'est un
monsieur du snob de faire le le
nettoyage qu'il aura beaucoup de travail
ah ouais et alors vous tue entre notre
sans gêne why et alors cabinet white est
ce que ça y est tu as vu dans quel état
du ray ce jardin ouais et alors et
bondir un dépotoir aux écoutes voyons
françois ne te fâche pas puisque c'est
une farce que je fais à monsieur de ce
noble puisque aujourd'hui dans notre
organisation c'est à lui de nettoyer le
jardin
très franchement casimir moi je trouve
pas que ce soit une très très bonne idée
de force
que vous est il arrivé libre venez vous
asseoir et qui sera présenté les projets
c'est une histoire stupide
figurez-vous que j'étais chez eux
d'excellentes ami à moi qui fais les
tableaux extraordinaire en lançant des
assiettes sur des planches enduite de
colle forte
c'est sublime tout à l'heure il me
montre quelques-unes de ses oeuvres
lorsqu'elle me disent tous deux je vais
vous montrer ma dernière elle va vous
tapez dans le et brusquement je me
retournais blond
elle était juste derrière moi et elle
vous a vraiment tapé dans l'oeil on peut
dire oui j'ai une grosse bosse sur le
front et qui la lie au beurre noir mais
ce qui me désole le plus c'est que
j'avais une réception monde est avec des
gens très important au marché vous allez
vous faire soigner par un médecin
oh j'ai pas le médecin mais pourquoi il
fait des piqûres j'ai horreur des pics
noms font me suis dit il ne faut pas se
conduire comme on est d abord allez
venez et puis aucune raison pour qu'on
vous fasse des piquets aller qu'on
croyait mais j'en suis sûr moi aller à
tout à l'heure
j'en ai pour une mine vous vous soignez
bien là
casimir qu'est-ce que ça revient s'il te
plaît ainsi à qui la tue c'est le
règlement sur les nettoyages dujardin
points
et alors quand quelqu'un nous est malade
c'est celui du jour d'après qui prend sa
place au loin et tu sais qui est inscrit
pour demain ben oui oui non non c'est
toi un casimir qui ça moi auj